but I'm currently in the middle of
speeches there's a good dozen or so
different organizations campaign groups
all standing for different things here
and the main point of today is to
protest against the government's Public
public order bill of course that gives
police more Powers when it comes to
tackling more serious and disruptive
protect protests and like I say there's
a variation of organizations who've got
just a boy or Extinction Rebellion
you've got Republic here black lives
matter UK a whole host of different
groups we're joined by Indigo rombello
she's a part of just stop oil Indigo
just sum up to me what today is all
about hi today is about getting together
and saying that is enough is enough
there is no point trying to criminalize
peaceful protests instead of
um looking at the root causes of these
problems the government here they're
pursuing a range of anti-strike laws
anti-migrant laws and anti-protest laws
and what they know they need to do is to
engineer oil and gas create Britain as a
decent place to work in
and you talk about there being no need
to police these peaceful protests but
the argument is it's the more serious
disruptive ones that this bill aims to
tackle just like just stop oil you know
locking onto motorways blocking roads
all of that so not peaceful ones the the
more disruptive ones so a few weeks ago
I was here at the coronation and I was
arrested for just wearing a t-shirt and
having a small small Banner in my pocket
and this this isn't the way to go about
it is it
yeah that's right there was backlash
with the coronation a arrest made in the
metropolitan police later did say they
expressed regret over that and that it
was so I was held for 16 hours and no no
regret has been expressed the the
investigation carries on and you think
this is a joke you know this is this now
carrying my bike bike lock into town I
could be arrested for just carrying this
bike lock what a ridiculous idea that's
not how we're going to stop the climate
crisis by arresting young people
carrying bike locks and yeah here's a
police evidence bag with um cable ties
and string in it you know what what
people are demanding is a proportionate
response to the situation that we're in
people watching today they are scared
about the climate crisis they want to
live in a Britain where we tax polluters
where we have um decent strike laws that
enable people to stand up for what they
believe in and instead the government is
just squishing people down before they
even get on this streets but when you
have those more disruptive protests you
know roads being blocked people being
blocked from going to work people I mean
so many reports when just a boy or had
blocked roads people trying to get to
hospital what about Public Safety yeah
Public Safety look it's a joke isn't it
this here Amplified sound is it is now
um you know you could be arrested for
just having Amplified sound bike Lots
luggage sashes it's just it's gone AWOL
but the point of this legislation being
it is when it's serious disruptive and
impactful on public on the public and
what I'm letting you know is that's not
how it's being used on the ground it's
being used to pick people off intimidate
young people coming out with their
cardboard signs saying they don't want
to cycle in it's intimidating ecologists
should be standing outside defra and uh
you know using a microphone to talk
about their research that isn't being
spoken about in the houses of Commons
okay Indigo we're gonna have to leave it
there I'll let you get back to the
speeches thank you for joining us so
various organizations out today on
Parliament Square uh protesting against
the public order bill